here comes conley
back to donovan mitchell step back long
to book it
this possession has to have joker
written all over it
murray has got 10 points 10 rebounds he
scoops up his 12th point
yo kitchen murray
murray fade away for the lead good got
it
denver's got the lead mitchell for the
tie and the scoop
go bare missing again inside he has
been very very
bad and there's a drive at the other end
murray puts it through look at this
behind his back
oh that is special wow that is
absolutely special if you knock down the
three and make it a free throw
game you cannot advance the ball as
mitchell with three gets
mitchell one point game seven point one
seconds and a quick foul donovan
mitchell
works by the defense takes it down got
the way up and puts it through
point nine to play game is tied at 105.
watch this no one to back up jokic
he floats in for two mitchell has come
up big
a miraculous three and two to tie it's a
back out to o'neal
conley in the corner three no ingalls
big time offensive rebound
conley three card counted in a foul
mike conley mitchell
making a move and a congested lane got
it counted foul
donovan mitchell continues to make big
baskets for the jazz
hands the double double double-double
22-11
a series of moves and easy to inside
over governor
thai game overtime mitchell trying to
get the lead
got it got it 3.4
mitchell's done it again there's morris
inbounding yogic
by o'neill for the tie and he gets it
with a move by
yokish look this is your center you put
the ball in his hands
the quick swipe through royce o'neil
free to fire jokic two to fire
blocked by murray short shot clock he'll
put up a fader
good what a shot by murray
look at this well how many step backs is
murray going to knock
down in this
on that biggest
put down by the terrific jeremy grant